欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
今天我们的贵买
也就是代表中小型股算是强谈的第三天
昨天的夜盘
我们看到台子期有先再度下杀千点
但是到了今天
现股一开盘又一切风平浪静
中场只有小跌了25点
大家难免要问了哦
这段时间以来我们看到的
不管美股财报台股营收
全部都是好消息
也等于是基本面真的没有什么样的改变
那现在要考验的就是
市场的情绪
有没有回到一个理性而合理的状态
在美股我们看到这样的现象
亚马逊公布财报之后
不管自由现金流转付
不管资本支出提高
股价照样创历史新高
道琼也創了历史新高
再再都在提醒我们
其实AI的趋势
在市场恢复理性的时候
是持续上行的
那么多的资本支出
将会变成台湾的订单
只是去杠杆种种的问题
我们要如何平复市场的情绪
来确认这个底部
有可能已经打出来了
就要来请今天三位来宾
好好的跟大家分享
不但有看法也有策略
首先我们来欢迎
AI达人蔡明翰
好 出国两个礼拜终于回来了
在他出国的时候
台股跌了将近9000点
说实话
就算对基本面也有高度信心
等会来告诉您
这些资本支出
完完全全就是我们的订单
可是有的股票跌了70%
伤害已经造成了
到底有没有机会把部位重建回来
明翰等一下帮您挑了
营销大幅成长
但股价已经砍到建股的
有哪一些达到平衡点
是值得布局的
好第二位是我们的古奇双分析师
季伟明小明同学
小明同学也要讲
大家昨天看到外资空单九万口
下呆了
但是这里面真的有很多叫做
套利型的空单
大家不要紧张
今天就降下来了
我们不如来看一下
昨天流民光学告诉大家
这个光通讯未来会比记忆体
可能还要缺哦
那我们的光通讯已经叫做
先叠先止叠
等一下帮您挑一下
那另外呢
封策类股订单从来没少过
可是股价少了一大块
这样的状况下
小明同学也帮您挑订单满手
又被错杀的封策股
第三位是我们的基金医生志愿哥
志愿哥也要提醒大家
昨天美国的ISM制造业指数
创下四年半以来的新高
制造业在扩张
这就代表景气势非常的好
再加上亚马逊的创高
代表AA的脚步
持續往前行
撒錢 撒錢 再撒錢
誰能拿到錢
我們
我們的半導體就是世界第一
這個不用懷疑了
所以在這段時間
如果您是持有ETF的朋友
誰能幫你報股票
其實被動式的半導體ETF
是可以幫你報股票
甚至發股息
這個股息可能還不用課稅
怎麼這麼好
等一下聽智元哥跟您說分明
首先有請我們已經休假兩週的
明翰哥
你是去哪裡的快回來出大事了
哇 這段時間你不在
台股一度跌了快要9000點
但是我們也看到
明明大家都在做資本支出啊
這不是應該是我們的底氣嗎
那現在風暴是不是正式已經過了
好 先講過往經驗
這兩三年來
通常我休假的時候都漲了
這次真的是破功了
跌都亂七八糟
是
我先強調一點
就是在休假前我一直講
股市會修正
其實真的跟基本面沒有太大的關係
尤其是當時是因為台積電法縮會過後
然後我就法縮會過後開始休假
我那時候講他財報真的講得很好
會他當然講得很好
會不會修正
這不一定是完全的直接相關
那大家會講到這一段時間修正
包含這個所謂的AI行情
是不是已經來到高點
或者是這個美衣衝突的關係
甚至在講這個
比如說南韓去槓桿之類的
我覺得老實講
這真的都不是很直接的關係
我們在等一下AI的部分
就講這個基本面就知道
美意衝突的結論永遠都一樣
最嚴重一定是3月
後面的偶爾震盪
其實都不會幅度太大
至於韓國這更容易了
怎麼容易 這個很慘
不是 我常常講
這個大家會把這個
怪到這個韓國身上
我會覺得這個
想一下就知道不合理
我回過頭來這近10年來
你曾不曾經台股會說
因為韓國漲所以我們要漲
韓國跌我們要跌
背伴為最重要的關鍵點
背伴美國人不會看到
南韓漲跌去買美股
我會講南韓會看美國
美國不會看南韓
所以最後的其實最大的兇手
還是在美國
那我們再講一個比較重要的問題
就是以這次的這個架構而言
所以我要休假的時候
剛好遇到台積電法說會講完
那我那時候定調要記得
不要看股價說話
不要因為他說
法縮會過後跌了7%
就說他不好
他講的真的都很好
沒有問題
股價不代表短線會反應他的基本面
說完之後你會發現
Google說完一樣重挫
那我在講
其實20年也有一樣的架構
我們等一下給大家看
就是說在漲多修正的過程當中
不管你說的再好都得跌
那什麼跌到什麼時候
跌到有一天一隔開之後
市場心情突然覺得
好像這些利空的便利多
尤其利多便利空或利空便利多
最重要的關鍵點就是資本支出
因為資本支出
他可以解讀成花那麼多錢
以後也不知道賺不住回來
突然又說
他會花那麼多錢
這是因為看好訂單才
所以我跟你講
這一次很明顯就從
等於說上禮拜四隔開之後
你會發現
微軟
我覺得微軟還不是很大的重點
因為微軟大漲
是因為他資本支出還沒有增加
重點是在Amazon
因為他拉高資本支出之後
出現大漲
我們等一下再講細節
我在講這24年曾經也發生過
前面三個月一路漲漲漲
漲到之後開始修正
所以會導致修正的過程當中
其實即使台積電把說會過後
也跌了接近7%
歷史從業就對了
這當時的一個架構也是一樣
然後重點是在這裡隔開
你會發現在這個隔開之前
Meta也是說資本支出增加
在這個隔開之前也是重挫
突然從這一天隔開之後
隔天說的都是大漲
然後就從這邊隔開之後
發生什麼事情
第一件事情樂觀之後打第二隻腳
後續就慢慢的往上
所以比較重要的關鍵點是在
市場的氛圍什麼時候轉變
我個人覺得其實上禮拜四
就是美股的那個氛圍之後
明顯就是導致台股在禮拜五有個大漲
其實就如同這一天的一個隔開
就市場的心情已經明顯的轉多
所以我覺得
結論而言就是兩點
第一個就是還是有可能會打第二隻腳
大家也不用認為會V型反彈
但我覺得最嚴重的架構
理論上應該已經過去了
再跟大家講一個證據
就是
這是美國三大指數
上面的是道瓊跟S&P500
這個是廢半指數
你可以看到高點從6月22號開始
廢半不斷的修正
可是這兩個指數都還在高檔
甚至剛才提到道瓊昨天還在創立
短期新高
那我常常講人家肯定感受不清楚
我故意抓了一個
比較誇張
應該說過去只要有長期修正
一定會發生一樣的事情
這是08年金融風暴的起跌點
你會發現當時不管
高或低之前有沒有漲
不管你
所有人一度都是漲著一樣
不斷的修正 指數打三折
在下殺的過程當中
只要景氣反轉
任何人不要告訴我
你基本面有多好
或是一樣都不重要
反正大家都得跌
所以很明顯就是這次跟景氣沒有太大的關係
完全就是因為
這一條線上半年漲了一倍
這兩個只有一成
所以這這麼簡單
所以現在就是在修正漲多而已
另外一個比較重要的重點
剛剛的
所謂的走勢不清楚
我們把它換成表格
就是這一次的這四家公司
把縮會錢跟把縮會資本支出的中間值
你會發現
Google Meta跟亞馬遜都有出現上修
只有微軟它還是維持
那比較重要的問題就是當時講
Google的自由現金流轉附
所以它股價隔天是中錯的
那講到一樣
亞馬遜它的資本支出增加了比它更多
自由現金流轉附比它更大
可是股價是大漲
所以很明顯就是從這裡切開之後
市場氛圍明顯轉多
另外就講因為這一次
大家都拉高資本支出之後
那外資馬上在
釋加公佈之後給一下
雲端資本支出的看法
你可以看到年初的時候
預估今年資本支出增加是36%
到財報這四家公布錢
已經拉到84%
從36到84
這就是今年上半年
為什麼會
所謂的AI俗信
漲這麼多的原因
就是從36調整到84
結果這四家公布之後
現在調整到93%
所以代表這個趨勢還在
確實我
剛剛趙華講的論點
其實如果理性來講
反正他們丟錢 我們就是賺錢
這是沒錯
可是市場氛圍不對
股價就會受到修正
所以這個兩點
應該這樣長線一定是走同趨勢
但短線會因為市場氛圍不同
所以你會看到股價跟基本面不同
但是一定只是短線 長線而言
你能夠多賺錢
你營收獲利能創高
你的股價就該創高
這是我一直覺得長期的一個看法
好 如果要再創高
還有機會回來嗎
我想這段時間一直跌的時候
大家的想法已經徹底沒有信心了
但是經過這個大漲
好像大家現在又重新燃起希望了
我個人覺得
結論我就覺得這個高點到底會過
我一樣回過頭來
台積電法說持續上修
大家都還是上修
下半年的台積電獲利
一定會比上半年更好
獲利能 說我剛剛講
獲利能 營收能創高 獲利能創高
股價就會創高
這是長期架構
所以我覺得
下半年指數再過高的機率是很高的
好現象就是這一段的修正過後
剛才提到這一條線出來之後
市場氛圍已經明顯反轉
我只是提供
我以前在講我543階梯布局
這個第一
所謂第一筆出現一定是橫向整理之後
出現恐慌爆量
殺出黑K棒
通常這裡看到技術面大家要跑
可是我就是正常來講
就是我買第一筆的時候
然後破底的時候再加碼
這可以買到三筆
那我剛剛講我就是五筆
那現在只有買到三筆
但是因為我個人覺得這條線一出來
就是我剛剛提到現在突然又講了
增加資本支出
突然變成利多了
所以代表著我自己猜想
我覺得第四筆買到的機會是不高
其實我要買第四筆
代表他要出現在這裡才會買第四筆
其實後續來講我覺得會震盪
但是再破底的機率我覺得是很低的
只是如果說下檔的時候
我覺得應該這樣講
再往下買是相對安全
但是再往下要買
通常就在逆人性
通常投資人比較可能比較不敢
而且那時候會很懷疑
是不是真的基本面有什麼問題
是我們沒發現
是但是我剛剛講
從台積電在這裡的時候就告訴你
它是上修的
但是我跟你講
因為股市再往下
誰來講大家都不信
我覺得這很正常的現象
但是後續呢
最主要問題就是這條線出來
大家現在都認為
AI資本支出增加
大家可以解讀成利多所以代表整個氛圍正向情況下我剛剛講的結論就是可以兩點第一點就是我覺得最大的風暴已經過第二點就是過往經驗它不會是V型反彈
它一定會在震盪
不過看加權指數
真的說實話對不對
以幅度來說還好嗎
兩成
可是個股不一樣
個股有的是腰斬
六成四成都有
好 我們看一下
我幫大家統計一下
從這個所謂的高點下跌
一直到昨天收盤價
其實我列出來個股
大概平均大概就是腰斬
接近五成左右
當然看到高一點接近七成
那低的平均來講
都有高於三成以上
所以大家市場確實是壓力蠻大的
那我的觀念就是
要記得在壓回的過程中有一個特色
就是市場不會去管
你到底有沒有基本面
在下殺的時候是人人都殺
而且最大的壓力點
來自於你之前漲多
或本益比偏高這兩個
反彈又有一個特色
跌升之後開始從底部上來
大家在追的時候
因為大家搶反彈
所以又開始不管你到底好與壞
可是我個人覺得
已經三天了
在後續的這個買盤
追加力道一定會慢慢縮減
所以這個時間點就是
這個檢視基本面
很好的一個時間點
那我們今天就幫大家列出來
可以看到跌幅
剛剛提到平均大概五成
那這些跌幅比較大的個股
CCL
波纖布 載板PCB專孔
這塊來講
可能就是跟PCB比較有關的
這個相關族群
那包含主動被動元件
那我這個幾個重點
第一個是看到本益比
第二個是看到
上半年的累積營收的成長
第一季已經公布了財報的年增率
你這三點去抓
就以這個德宏來講
本益比有亮燈
就代表我覺得他本益比超過百倍
真的有點高
你要記得就是說
好 他現在跌幅7成
可是他本益比其實還160倍
所以相對而言
不代表說它跌七成你就能買
這個是概念先跟大家分析
累積營收超過三成
等於你有過平均
低劑獲利也超過三成以上
最後就會有個黃燈
就是黃線的部分
就代表三個都有達到標準的
但是其中國劇我要稍微提一下
雖然營收確實
39 29大概就是30
所以我覺得這是達標的
可是有個問題
就是它整體產業
其實大部分都是沒有到達均標的
可是他們有的人6月有跳起來
對 所以我意思說
這個族群真的有點尷尬
就是他的5 6月真的
就是已經有好轉了
那現在有達君子的國聚
他是有靠著合併加成
那其他人是不達君子
所以我覺得應該這樣講
這個族群他真的跌的很深了
所以我覺得現在反彈是合理的
那再來就是
剛才提到5 6
他的營收真的有往上拉
現在馬上要公布7月
他是不是能夠再往上墊高
就是他們反彈後續的一個很重要動能
我覺得是比較要持續關注的
那剛剛除了
剛剛產業之外
包含成熟製程的聯電
他也是累積營收
有點類似也是後續有比較好
但是累積營收還遠不及均值
那也是希望7月能夠再往上跳
不然我覺得他的漲勢可能也會
稍微有壓
那其中都符合包含雍智
包含環宇KY的部分
還算是都有達標
那可以看到矽晶圓
矽晶圓或者是矽光值
確實有很多個股
之前漲很多 最近跌得很深
但是
它的基本面來講也有稍微跟不上
好 所以大家很聰明
黃黃黑黑的看黃色的
黃明已經整理出來了
應該是說你現在
我們剛剛就提到
最差的狀況已經過了
它有機會持續往上走
但也有機會
可能有可能會打第二隻腳
如果回來打第二隻腳
我會建議盡量買數字都對的個股
相對來講會比較安全
好 接下來第二季財報
也要陸續開出來了
可以把它自動加進來
自己也算一下
對 然後所以呢
個股的部分我們今天
就分析給大家看
就是分享一下台藥的部分
你可以看到從19
幾乎腰斬了
就是相對而言真的有蠻大的跌幅
但是一樣的問題
就是從本益比或者是
低劑的獲利到上半年的營收
都是表現很好的
那剛才最近營收正在公布
當然也是一個檢視很好的標準
但最基本而言就是
跌升數字都沒有太大的意外
那最近
應該說外資的賣壓有稍微減輕
投信的部分有稍微轉買
所以我覺得這塊來講
大家可以留意
那另外呢 這個所謂的
載版
對 載版族群
我覺得其實基本面都是很好
那南電的拉回的空間
相對比較大一些
所以我覺得是可以關注的
那這個籌碼面來講
就是最近
之前投信賣比較多
最近稍微休息
但還是維持正向
那這個本來就是所謂的內置的股票
所以投信的這個動向
相對是比較關注的
但我覺得籌碼面是比較短線的
他重點是在他的剛剛提到
從獲利到營收都是非常正向
所以我就看法很簡單
就是後續來講
盡量報還是有數字的個股
那從剛剛提到
從上半年的一個營收
包含低劑的獲利
最後把可能這週
即將公布的七月營收也納進來一起考量
我覺得
這樣的都對的個股
相對來講抱著安心
那很簡單的道理
就像我們前段講的台積電一樣
上半年好 下半年會創高
代表股價應該都還有創高機會
代表高點應該都有機會再突破
也等於是假如
台股還有機會再打所謂的第二隻腳
因為按照過去的經驗是還會有
因為談到這邊有人會賣
那這些股票就是優先在打腳的時候
要逢低減便宜的
是
好 這邊非常謝謝迷漢哥
好 迷漢哥出國兩個禮拜回來
知道大家的心
根本就是一個受創的狀態
但是就是論事
基本面如果還是很好的話
殺得越深反而代表機會反彈
你越有信心喔
好 那剛剛列出來了
好多股票是一個腰斬的狀況
可是如果累積營收是繼續往上走呢
甚至最近在公佈7月營收
不妨加進來
第二季的季報加進來
那这些超跌的股票刚刚选出来了
不管是PCB相关的载版类的等等的
其实都有好股票藏在里面
等着您发掘以及给自己添信心
广告回来小明同学要上场了
证交所昨天立刻把处置股的规定给改了
这件事情到底对我们有利吗
还有就是流明光学
给光通讯打了一记强心针
这个产业是不是真的已经落底完成
要上功了呢
好 关于台股的流动性
哇 这个也是一个大事情
昨天下午证交所好快
把我们的储置股条款
紧急的改了
现在就变成两分钟撮合
而且最长只要关七天
这到底对我们的整个交易来说
是不是真的叫解禁
对于大户有好处
对于我们小散户有没有好处
这边来讨论了
好像很奇怪
这叫一刀切
就是刚刚明翰有提到的
前面什么事情都讲不起来
後面要改啊
然後要怎麼樣啊
都可以把它講起來了
處置股也可以馬上改革
然後昨天的9萬空單
今天有降下來了
再來的話
昨天流民光學也講了
我們光通訊是很厲害
現在很缺料
未來的需求很大
再來風車也說
我們的訂單從來沒掉過
那就從裡面來幫我們找股票吧
對 我們等一下這邊
會來幫大家追蹤
我覺得現在有很多的交易機會
再加上制度上面的利多
我自己蠻看好後面行情
應該會漸入佳境
你就是樂觀小明啊
你也沒變過啊
當然啦 樂觀啦
豆先生也是很樂觀嘛
那我個人啦
先幫大家整理一下
就是關於在這次的處置心製
到底有什麼變化
這些啦
就是從原本你可能關10天的
現在就是砍半
我關5天
原本因為當充比太高
你要關12天的
就是再加關你兩天
變成關7天
一樣是砍半
那原本5分鐘搓一盤
20分鐘一盤
以後都改成2分鐘
搓一盤
這個其實幾乎就是
你有點類似過去可能零股交易的
那一種感覺
所以這個流動性
應該算是非常非常的充分
那麼過去一直被人家詬病的是
你六日的價差大於100
可能就會列警示
會導致聯發科台積電
莫名其妙有可能就會被抓去關
所以新智過後就會容許更大的價差
我覺得這一點會差特別的多
另外就是
實施日馬上試用
8月10號
如果你前面已經關超過5天的
那這個時候你當天馬上就出去了
特色天下
對 有一點類似這種感覺
就是你只要在8月10號當天
那你前面已經關購的
那你當天就會直接出關
那我們來聊一下關於新制度的好處
我個人是樂見其成啦
那至於是不是大戶條款
對於大戶來講啦
因為你流動性改善
他們更容易出股票
可是對於一般的散戶來講的話
你的股票比較不容易被關
或者是你被關了
你一樣有辦法去做買賣
那這個時候我認為
其實對於整個資本市場來講
它是一個往更健全交易制度
發展的方向
所以我們給他一個讚
給我一個讚好不好
說改就改
那昨天大家很關心的外資空單9萬口
不知道到底是為了避險還是套利
但你說今天看來真的昨天是為了
鄭家超的套利
對 因為其實昨天看到了這個外資的
未平常空單來到9萬口
可是很顯然的
那應該對我來講叫做套利
因為在上禮拜五的時候
期貨的收盤價比現貨的收盤價
高了整整500多點
這也是為什麼昨天禮拜一的時候
你一開盤其實現貨並沒有跌很多
因為期貨已經跑在太前面
那你期貨漲的太多
法人會做什麼動作
他會去賣期貨 去買現貨
這就造成了我們所謂的套利
所以昨天的空單大增
我自己的解讀上面
會比較偏向是套利單
這也是為什麼你空單來到了9萬多口
可是今天的台股卻沒有大跌
因為它不是一個方向性的交易
那你在今天這個期貨的正價差
收斂了以後
甚至變成逆價差
反而外資這邊就把他的空單給回補了
所以我們在做這樣子的解讀
外資的空單來到了9萬多口
我昨天是沒有特別擔心
反而是在微台的部分
今天又繼續的
這個多單降低下來
這代表是後面其實指數反彈的
這個延續的動能
應該是有機會繼續下去
然後再來產業也來好消息了
流民光學就講說
零化音比記憶體還要缺
奇怪 就開始幫CPU喊話了
光通訊就開始點火
那當然啦
零化音本來這一件事情
缺我們也不是在這一兩天的事情
那無論如何我們現階段看到的
就是在這些國際的龍頭
他們到底動向怎麼樣
在上禮拜的時候 AXT有開財報
股價大噴特噴
那AXT會噴最主要就是
因為跟流民光學Lumantan
他們這邊的合作簽了一個長約
這個長約要到2031年底
你一旦要簽長約
代表這些下游的廠商他想要拿產呢
更特別的地方在於訂金支付
一般來講啦
這些就算簽長約也是你貨交給我
我再把錢給你
可是現在Lumantan說
我直接第一筆我簽約
我就直接先給你4350萬美元
就是合約的一半
那再來第三個叫做採購的承諾
這個也算是至少在我
我擔任分析師的時候
我好像沒有看過這個東西
這個是什麼呢
他承諾我每一年會採購多少的量
如果我實際的採購量
低於我承諾的採購量
在沒有特殊事件的情況之下的話
我要把這些差額呢
把錢交給你
保底啊
就是保底
應該是可以的吧
保底啊 我當然要買那麼多啊
對 所以這代表是
Lumantan他有非常強烈的信心說
就是會缺 我一定要先拿到
一定要先買
所以AXD股業就大漲
那當然啦 我們今天整理的這個
我覺得大家可以截圖一下
因為這張表格已經把我們台股的
上中下游在CPO的部分
特別是跟零化音有關的
公司我幾乎都列出來了
因為大家聽到什麼零化音啊
深化價 早就已經頭昏了
這張表就幫你整理出來
跟零化音有關的
沒錯 暗表操課 存起來
第一個 上游累積
這個一定是第一個動的
我們當時在週末看到這則新聞的時候
我大概就有感覺應該會由上往下
所以前面昨天全新其實已經漲停
上禮拜我就漲停
所以他是三天三根漲停聯尼亞也是一樣就是第一線會攻上去IET也是為什麼 因為他們是上游的累金那你到了中游以後呢穩帽其實昨天沒有漲停當然今天我們說的它會開始向下傳導
所以穩帽今天就攻上漲停
環宇KY其實也被歸類在中游
這個是我們上禮拜有分享的
等一下會來幫大家追蹤
同樣的我覺得中游在現在這一塊
資金現在集中的是在上游跟中游
可是因為你畢竟前面反彈了
如果有一些下游的包含像是封裝測試
那在現在股價反彈的幅度還沒那麼大
反而就有後面接棒的機會
包含像是3450的聯軍啊 不錯嘛
過去也會把它當成是光收發模組
但他其實是做封測的
訊息KY等一下會來聊
那包含潛艇 華星光跟仲達
這些基本上我們可以把它歸類在
下游的封裝測試
所以上面的已經動了
我認為下面就有機會去做接棒
那我們來看一下以選股上面的話
我同樣的在這段期間裡面
都是用籌碼來幫大家選股
所以20日的鎖定率
一樣由高到低去做排列
你會發現是不是越高的
股價越容易漲停板
不過現在是不是大家普遍鎖定率
也不容易拉的太高
因為大戶前一波也有受傷
沒錯
就等於是前面主力券商
他有經過調節
因此你現在這個地方要看到大於1不容易
但是你只要有看到這個數字
相對偏高在整個族群裡面的
通常在這邊的延續動能都會比較強
那除了鎖定率以外
外資在這邊買的比例重不重
我們可以看到光通訊
我在前兩個禮拜都有跟大家強調
外資是有在逢低買的
那果然的他們超底成功
那以現在來講的話
在近期可以看到
累積營收年增率跟月營收年增率
大部分除了少數幾間
不然的話這邊幾乎都是大於的
所以這代表什麼
他們的營收是有在漸入加進
因此以光通訊來講
今年下半年
我們可以先優先看這些營收
開的出來的公司
再加上籌碼來幫我們挑選
這個時候勝率就會蠻高的
好 加上他們的修正
其實有相當大的幅度
如果有產業的背書
那大家信心可以回來了
因為我們之前也有聊過
前面一波漲上去
它漲的是反映未來的估值
那你估值太高
下跌叫做估值修正
那你估值經過修正
風險就降低了
而且那時候還很多鬼故事
對你下跌什麼事情
都會變成鬼故事
出報告啦
說要2028才有啦什麼的
沒錯
那在這裡的話
因為你各種的鬼故事跟利空
它就會把底部測試出來
我們先看2455全新
以全新來講的話
當然它在做累積
這個連續撥雷射的累積
台灣應該在這個部分
全新應該算是No.1
以產能來講的話算是大的
所以目前來講
它已經開始出現了這種
我們說的你產品可以出貨
那再加上它有新增MOCVD
化學氣象成績的設備
從三台到五台
這個成長幅度是66%
所以產能資本支出上調
對於公司的營收後面來講
會有進一步墊高的效果
那再來的話
我們可以看到的是以光電子的部分
它的營收占比是持續的上升
所以光通對於全新來講
它的重要性是越來越高
股價即便來到了現在
將近要談到季線的位置
但是因為光通真的是修正太多了
那外資在近期雖然有調節一下
可是整體的水位跟過去相比
還是在一個相對高檔
所以我不認為全新在這邊
馬上就會反彈結束
而且這裡原本有一條下降的
這個趨勢線
所以它是有突破下降的壓力
最近是不是蠻多可以看這個
突破下降壓力的
所以等於是它突破了以後
那在這個位置
他了不起啦回測個五日均線以後
他應該就會再攻
所以我覺得全新在這個位置上面
依然有投資的價值
那第二間公司就是我們上禮拜
介紹過的4991的環宇KY
不過他真的喔
也是這樣子正啊正
但年限也上去了
對 我們當時在年限附近講
我們講完要兩天兩根跌停
這總算是打第二隻腳了吧
對我來講我會這樣說服自己啦
會比較有信心爆料
講完兩根兩根跌停還來
都已經那麼低了
那你後面果然三天
三根漲停板就還大家
好又收幅了
這波動太大了
但因為純度高啦
這個就是基本面的信仰
那我們有講過了
它的市佔率超過七成
以現在來今年的預估1PS7.26
明年17.22是一個翻倍以上的成長
所以它確實可以享有一個更高的本益比
那我們可以看到的是以近期來講
外資這五個交易日
依然是站在買方
所以它的股價
它有沒有突破下降壓力線
這邊我就不連了
我連這邊
其實它是有突破下降壓力線的
因此它距離季線還有好大一段空間
我會認為環宇KY的純度竟然夠高
股價修正的幅度也大
代表它後面反彈的力道
應該一樣有機會可以延續下去
好 已經測試兩次年線了
往上走了
年線附近 已經有打底了
那這邊的話封測類
事實上封測也在強調
他們都在擴產
對啊 先進封裝的需求是供不應求
那先進封裝裡面
這一次應該也有很多的訂單
是來自於CPU
那我們同樣的不免俗的
從鎖定率來整理
這裡就有大V的囉
真的耶
這裡就有大於1了
等一下這個不是之前被搜索嗎
對 可是因為我覺得他這邊的
籌碼會這麼集中
是因為其實最近這20個交易日
外資竟然買了將近
超過8個百分比的股本
這個數字很大 非常的大
所以他反彈的力道也很強
那在這段期間裡面
大部分還有融資的變化
融資斷頭斷的很乾淨的是訊星KY
那鎖定率最高的也是訊星KY
外資也有在買
所以我們去觀察到了
他其實營收的數字
我覺得大家可以簡單去做一下對比
這種月營收大於累積
營收的年增率的
這個代表他的營收有在加速
所以我們一樣整理這張表格
基本上我覺得這張表格
你就算放到最後面的日月光頭控
應該在今年下半年的營收數字
都還是會非常漂亮
對 雖然今天大哥沒漲
但是我們來看一下中小型的
中小型我們先看
這6451的訊星KY
這個位置非常有吸引力
第一個啦
他在四月份的字節EPS就翻證了
所以他是一個轉虧為營的公司
6月份的營收更是年增40%
這個事情就是我們說的營收有在加速
另外公司法說會上面直接說
台積電的Cube矽光子平台有合作
再加上訊星KY本身就是鴻海集團
所以鴻海集團他們要做伺服器的組裝
那他會不會同時具備伺服器跟交換器
還有模組的資源一起挹注進來
這個可能性就大
那再加上他的資本支出
是要擴大到40到50億
最主要就是要去建構
CPU的自動化產線
而且越南新廠
現在目前已經開始準備要去做投產
所以一旦有新廠要開始做投產
營收就會往上墊高一級
那我們以技術型態來講的話
雖然上方啦被月線壓著
可是我們講過了
你上方的這邊月線
其實它耗勞量並不大
你真正會遇到壓力的是在這塊
這邊是有壓力的 有量能的
所以對過來的話
大概要到快要600塊錢才會有壓力
那以目前的股價來講的話呢
它其實上方我個人看的壓力會是在季線附近
所以呢
距離520塊錢
大概上方也都還有將近快要三成的空間
那我會認為外資在近期
我們剛才看過了
這個籌碼集中度非常的高
外奔幣也非常的高
那這類型的公司
你在這個地方的話呢
融資前面經過了一波清洗
外資又站在買方
這種籌碼穩定的
他一樣反彈的空間就會呢
非常值得期待
好 那我們下一個來看一下
371的日月光頭控
大哥 今天怎麼沒表現呢
因為前兩天是漲停板
我覺得這種大型股
他已經跑兩天讓他休息一天
那再來的話我們觀察到的是
前面外資這邊都是持續站在賣方
可是外資卻在昨天
漲停板的時候他是站在買方
投信本來就是不離不棄
所以等於是這邊是土洋了
沒有對坐了 開始有共識
那股價因為剛好上方遇到月線反壓
我覺得反而今天這邊的震盪
讓籌碼短線上面的獲利了結
消化完以後後面再攻的機率會比較大
同樣的熱光除了本來的先進封裝以外的話
他也完成了CPO元件的展示
所以你要說他是CPO概念股嗎
他也有站到邊
那因為股價的跌幅其實不算深
所以後面這邊的套牢壓力並不大
那我認為日月光
他是一個長線多頭的股票
股價的目標價
我們有看到法然已經喊到了四位數
所以這個地方要去挑戰前高
我個人認為沒有到特別的困難
因此日月光即便在今天跌了四個百分點
但如果明後天
他在這邊又繼續的下跌或震盪的話
對於我來講
他可能就是給前面沒有上車的投資朋友
重新一次上車的機會
等於你今天的排序
從高波動的到如果真的不敢
那日月光的業績也是非常好的
全職股來做一個壓
壓對對不對
大家做一些資金的配置
可是有鱸門騰這樣講
其實大家對光通訊的前景
應該要很放心才對
買的安心抱的放心
好這邊非常謝謝小明同學
小明同學說
像這個儲置股的條件放寬
事實上對於我們的自由交易
這個事情是有幫助的
而且可以看得出來
我們從善如流的政府
是希望把盤稍微護一下的
但回到產業面
CPU每次在下跌的時候
我們都講說
因為可能未來的應用還很遠
業績還沒有完全開出來
但是流民光學
他已經證明了這個東西很缺
願意簽長約
而且有些CPU的業績也已經開始上來了
所以這邊從高波動一路排到
相關風測的向日月光
大家可以根據自己的風險承受度
著亮來布局這個已經先跌
先止跌的產業
好 廣告回來
我們的基金醫生資源哥要上場了
基金醫生資源哥要告訴大家
ISM製造業指數創下四年半的高
美國的景氣也很好
所以同樣的看到亞馬遜創高
我們也可以期待
我們台灣的半導體有機會創高
有哪一檔的被動CTF
可以幫你一網打盡呢
等一下來教您囉
好 我們剛剛也特別聊到
市场的情绪似乎凌驾在基本面之上
可是一刀切就从亚马逊开始
如果今天订单会来台湾
哪一个族群最受惠
我想半导体
我们是全世界最强的
毋庸置疑
所以这边来请教我们的基金医生
今天的气氛又不一样了
上个礼拜在杀的时候
真的感觉上是多头已经结束了
可是我们从基本面来看
美国的ISM制造业指数在创高
我们的AI抢风头
亞馬遜在創新高
那所以呢這段時間
如果能夠度過波動
可能被動式的ETF加上半導體
加上有配息
這個是最穩定的
對其實呢台股7月份波動還蠻大的
那很多個格都殺身濃濃對不對
但是呢我們回到就是說
到底台股還能不能再重返榮耀
我覺得跟美股
還是有很大的一個關係
那美股能不能再創新高
其實我覺得以美股的危機來看的話
除了肺半修正比較嚴重之外
其實他我都覺得還好
那你說非半嚴重嗎
我覺得也還好
為什麼上半年漲了101%
那修正一點我覺得是應該的
那我們看到窮其實有在續創新高
那標普的部分也在新高附近
所以這個部分來講的話
當然跟美國的經濟
有很大的一個關係
美國第二季的GDP是1.5%
其實我覺得不算差
那如果從一個比較細項來看的話
我覺得製造業是一個
非常重要的一個指標
那我們看到美國7月份的
ISM製造業指數的部分
其實是連續性的超過50
那這個是非常好的一個狀況
大家都知道50是一個
警戒的一個榮枯線
大於50基本上就是整個整個警戒賽擴張
那還能夠持續好幾個月往上衝
代表美國的經濟真的是不錯
衛接上來看我們剛剛講到
道瓊有創新高 標普在新高附近
那非半稍微的修正
但是波段反彈其實都還蠻強的
我們來看一下亞馬遜的一個
股價的一個部分
這兩根K如果你不要看的時候
以為要走空了
對 你以為它要跌破頸線了
但是馬上拉兩根給你看
因為它的一個基本面
整個扭轉它的一個技術面的一個部分
其實我覺得這個會慢慢延伸到
其他的一個美股巨頭的一個部分
是值得大家留意的一個部分
那如果美股好
這些訂單包括AI半導體都好的話
會好到誰
那一定是我們
因為我們有最堅實的
AI供應鏈的一個部分
我們還有很多護國神山群
不是護國神山 護國神山群
那我們來看一下就是說那好到哪一些呢我們就以上半年是賺錢的那么第二个就是投信法人持有的个股里面是最多的
那我们来看一下
这几个个股里面
你像台积电跟联发科的部分
总共都有
台积电就有800多档的基金
持有它
那联发科也有500多档基金
所以你就知道
那个集中度是非常高
他们就是用这样的
优异的一个基本面
去吸引投資法人的一個進駐的部分
其他像什麼
聯電 日月光 自貿這些
大概都有200多檔的基金在持有它
其他像矽晶圓的部分也有
環球晶的部分也是市場的焦點
接下來我們就要來看一下
好好來看一下
我覺得當然禮拜五
今天一跳台積電漲停板
我覺得漲3000多點都還好
台積電漲停板
這是非常振奮人心的一件事情
而且漲停板之後
整個下降趨勢線
其實都已經突破了
那這兩天雖然沒有漲
但是呢
技術面上面來講
我覺得還是整個台股裡面
算相當強的
所以它給大家一個
非常大的一個信心
那其實台積電的一個法說
我覺得現在大家都這樣
不是只要考95分
要考100多分
要考105分
對 都是要這樣子
但是如果我們真的從
它的一個資本支出來看的話
你會發現到怎麼樣
先进制程的部分
占了将近有八成的部分
那先进封窗的部分
也将近有20%
所以这些呢
其实都是最赚钱的一个部分
那你像发哥也是一样
这你看这个基本面
连长两根
所以在基本面上面
我觉得这两个
护国深山给大家一个
很好的一个定心丸
就是说
AI的多头其实是没有结束的
是
好一个IC设计龙头
一个晶圆制造龙头
那再来呢
告诉大家就是说
其實民漢第一段的時候有提到
這四大CSB資本支出
我們看整體的狀況來看一下
就是說其實是持續的往上漲
我們從06年今年的7000多億
明年8000多億
可能在後年的部分
有將近1兆美元以上
所以我們看到這整個巨浪的部分
就延伸到就是說包括
先進製程的部分
AI、GPUI、ASIC、晶片
其實持續蓬勃發展的
還有包括先進封裝的部分
还有整个记忆体的部分
其实呢
我最近才买了一个苹果电脑
今天看到新闻说记忆体缺
所以呢
MacBook Air可能会缺货
我在苹果调涨价格的那一天
其实有点懊悔
但我就想到
亚马逊可能会有
我回头一看
没有调涨
马上下单
我就直接省了一万五
难怪他的自由现金有转负
就是你
他这个
不管怎么样
他告诉你就是说
其实四大CSP厂
資本支出
對整個AI來講
它是一個擴散的效應
所以不管包括Dram的
這些單片晶圓的產值也好
或者是環球晶12吋晶圓的ASP也好
你看其實曲線都是持續大幅成長的
所以這個來講的話
是好到很多不同的一個階段
那我們剛剛講說
那個記憶體
讓我的MacBook Air缺貨對不對
你看南亞科
7月營收爆充
哇 月增多少
5成
月增五成
很驚人
月增
而且叫去年来讲
其实也是大增好多
720%
其实非常非常高
好夸张
那之前有利空消解的环球金
因为这个市创的关系
对 任劣市创的亏损
对 价值坚顺
对 但今天的法说
也传来好消息
上半年EPS11块多
整体来讲
我觉得也是非常好的
当然任劣的一个部分的话
后面来讲有可能是
下半年也有可能回充
也有機會的
所以整個來講
基本面它跌很深
現在來講的話
我覺得就是說
整個AI面來講的話
就是說整個把這些消息消化之後
我覺得會慢慢回到
所謂的一個基本面的一個部分
好 那如果說我要打包這些半導體
我的晶圓代工 先進製程
封裝 細晶圓 其實好多
而且跌下去的時候
其實我們人的成就率
對個股真的沒有辦法
你說環球晶那麼好
殺下去我還是怕
對啊 所以我要一檔一檔買不容易
殺下去的話整串殺下去
也是很嚇人一件事情
所以我常常建議大家
就是說你可以用ETF來打包這些
因為真的太多元了
好 那我們今天就很專注在
所謂在AI半導體上面
其實台灣出了蠻多
這樣的一個主題式的ETF
那我們來看一下這些
上半部是這些科技型的
那除了台灣之外
然後還有像費半的
也有在裡面
那下半部深藍色的部門
主動的部分
那我們來看一下第一名
上半年績效第一名
也是股票型ETF
今年上半年的第一名是
00913的兆豐特選
台灣晶圓製造
好特別 台灣晶圓製造
不得了 上半年是126.7%
我們一直在講主動很厲害
那我們981A
這個搖池積姆很厲害
沒有錯
在這個主動式上半年是第二名
它也是92.6
差了30幾個%
被動式比較有幫大家
報波段的能力
沒錯 其實就是我講的重點
就是說有時候
你覺得它的缺點
有時候變成好處
因為我們之前常常在講說
這個被動式的半導體
你要等到換股的時間才能換
你不能主動換
可是如果你是AI的半導體的趨勢
是一個波段的狀況底下
這種選股的方式
它可能半年一換的方式
可以幫你牢牢的抓住波段的利潤
比你我們講說滾石不升胎
常常換來換去不是不好
但是有可能你就會錯失
這個中間的一個波段的行情
所以在主被動裡面
其他的主動包括91、947
這些在今年上半年
都有超過倍數的漲幅
那如果我們以成長規模來看的話
也是以913最厲害 為什麼
我覺得應該績效特別好的關係
讓投資人注意到它
所以你看到這今年的一個規模成長
成長了700多個%
所以這個成長的幅度是很大的
因為它的一個績效的部分
是相當相當的一個搶眼
績效就是最好的行銷
對 沒錯
那我們就要來看一下00913
它的組成
其實這檔蠻特別
剛剛趙華有提到就是說
它其實是一個上 中 下 油
全部都打包的
不是只重視在其中一個部分
因為我們剛剛看到那個榜單
也有特別重視在上游
IC設計的部分
它就是全部都有
上游的部分它有哪一些
它有IC設計還有IP的部分
35%
如果有IC設計來講
好像聯發哥當作一個代表
那麼中游的部分
晶圓代工
那當然就是有我們的
台積電
那先進製程的一個部分
成熟製程的部分
它有聯電跟世界先進的部分
是屬於晶圓代工的部分
那低潤的部分呢
它有誰 它有滑邦電
其實全中都還蠻高的
前幾大的一個持股的部分
大概就是十幾%
到二十幾%的一個部分
那在下游的部分來講的話
它也有所謂封測
剛剛提到的日月光的部分
致貿的部分也有在裡面
還有在基板的部分
其實都有在裡面
所以我們看到就是說
因為它是一個被動
被動就要等到換股的時候
才能夠做所謂的一個
调整持股的一个部分
所以你看它这个股价的一个涨幅
真的是还蛮惊人的
所以可以在上半年的一个部分
创造出超过120%的一个报酬率
那虽然7月份
有所谓乱流的一个部分
也还是会被伤到
可是你的这个幅度
比起很多个股
动不动都是三五成以上的
这种跌幅来讲
我觉得算是还算好
而且反弹会跟马上跟
对 没错 这是还蛮明显的
所以这个部分要提醒大家留意
那我们刚刚讲到就是说
009有几个特色
那不是只有绩效
它的绩效的领先来自于
就是说它全面性的上中下游的
半导体都有
那第二个呢是有配置的一个部分
它以这个台积电为出发点
那延伸到其他的中下游的一个部分
都有在里面
所以呢护国神山群的部分
基本上来讲
它是一个蛮完整的一个生态链
那第三个人的部分呢就是说
因为它不是主动
所以它就不会有人为判断的一个部分
机械式的帮你抱着
对抱着
就是整个把波段的利润给抱好抱满
所以这个状况来讲
也是它整个三大优势的一个部分
那虽然它是一个被动
很冲
你看它这个配置的部分非常的冲
但是呢
它也兼顾到就是说
有帮投资人想到
你想要现金流的
它也有
而且它有个好处
因为你看它持股就知道
就是说
对像台积电虽然有配息
但是如果这个配息率来讲是偏低的
所以它大部分來講的話
應該都是在所謂資本利得的部分
那8月18號的部分
它也要迎來它半年度的一個配息
那這次的配息是
每單位1.78元
那如果換算當期的一個配息率的話
就是4%多一點點
那整個年化來講就是8%
那如果想要參與配息的一個投資朋友的話
就可以在8月18號之前
最晚是8月17號買進這一檔的一個ETF
那當然還是最後建議大家
因為它是一個波動性比較大的
我們還是要根據你的這個風險屬性
來做一個配置
所以如果你是一個比較積極型的
我會比較建議就是說
我們剛剛那個績效表
裡面有很多半導體的這個ETF
被動式的
你就可以配置差不多40%
那其他的部分包括像市值型的部分
你也可以配置30%
再搭配一些主動型的一個部分
那還有少部分的高息
那如果你是一个
比较保守的投资朋友的话
在这个部分的话
比例可以降低一点
市值型相对放多一点
再搭配一些债券
但是不能够买长债
你要买这个存续
比较短的
这个债券的部分
再强调一下
再搭配比较多的高股息的ETF
我觉得这样配置来讲
在这个波动的一个时代
就是你积极的
想赚资本利得的
你也可以配置
那如果在这个波动
你比较怕的投资朋友
你也有一个
比較保守的一個配置
好基金醫生
很想要很多產品都很熟
很想要講
那因為半導體的ETF相當多
這檔的名字我想也特別的
有特色
它叫兆豐台灣晶圓製造
上中下游都有
而且配息不高不低
也是個蠻舒服的配息
又可以避免所得稅太高的問題
對 沒錯
好 這邊非常謝謝紫元哥
好 每次講到半導體
就真的覺得好驕傲
因為我們就是延續著台積電
不只護國神山
更是護國群山
所以剛剛資源哥也講到了
其實上中下游在這波跌下來的時候
每一個產業每一個領域
他都有很強的底氣
但是誰能夠一網打盡呢
我們今天跟大家分享的是00913
趙鋒的台灣晶圓製造
他就是涵蓋了上中下游
以及他最後如果要參與他的除息
買進日是8月17號
他的息也不高不低
剛剛好
符合你想要現金流
符合你想要創造績效的時候
他跟得上
虽然这波回档也有回
但是反弹也马上弹上去
提供给您做参考
但是赵华还是要提醒
投资基金投资ETF
都是有赚有赔有风险的
申购钱一定要享阅公开说明书
今天非常谢谢三万一来到现场
以贵买来说
周小行股算是反弹的第三天
而且反弹的很急
有很多人很担心
会不会弹完了后面没有
但是今天我们跟大家分享的
就是所谓产业的底气
这波下跌可能星星飞走了
现在我们重新建立真的还不晚喔
那也希望今天的理财答案秀
对你投资有帮助
明天再会了
拜拜